المترجم: Aya AlAjjan
المدقّق: Khadra Salem
مرحباً TEDx!
السلام عليكم.
مبدئياً لي الشرف وسعيد جداً
بأنني موجود بينكم اليوم.
بعيداً عن مجال الدراسة والعمل
الذي اعتدت عليه في حياتي،
أكثر شيءٍ كنت أخاف منه قديماً
هو الوقوف على المنصة أمام الناس،
لكني بدأت ألعب شيئاً يدعى Beatbox،
أو Human Beatbox،
وهو نوع من أنواع الموسيقى.
وهذا ما كنت أجسد به جملةً
لطالما أحببت أن أقولها:
وهي: "كيف تمثل الحريّة بحريّة؟"
ما هو الـBeatbox مبدئياً؟ هو مثلاً ..
--
هذا هو الـBeatbox.
(تصفيق)
شكراً.
بدأ Beatbox بتقليد للأصوات
كما نقلد أصوات الأشخاص مثلاً،
الحيوانات،
الآلات بشكل عام،
لكننا كنا ننظر إلى الأشياء الأخرى
كالسيارات والدراجات والطيارات،
فكانت تبدو لنا أصوات نصدر
أصواتاً مثلها، مثلاً:
(تقليد صوت المِرْوحيّة)
هكذا بدأنا نحن.
لكننا لم نفهم ما كنا نفعله،
تبين فيما بعد أنها تسمى
Human Beatbox.
إنها شيء رائع ومنتشر في الغرب.
أندمجت في هذا الموضوع كثيراً،
ما نفذته منذ قليل هو من الجيل القديم
وهو تقليد صوت الطبل:
--
هكذا..
ما أقصده بالجيل هو أن تقلد مثلاً
الـ DJ،
DJ, Prague, Blooper وهكذا.
كيف يمكنك أخذه ووضعه بداخلك،
وتقليده بصوتك البشري.
سأؤدي لكم شيئاً صغيراً كـ DJ
أتمنى أن يعجبكم:
--
هذا ما وصلنا إليه مؤخراً.
(تصفيق)
بعد ما تطورنا في هذه اللعبة
بدأنا نقسمها لعدة أجزاء،
بعد ما أخرجناها من اللاشيء، أصبحت
متضمنة في الهيب هوب بشكل عام-
أنا واحد من عشاق الموسيقى والهيب
هوب بالذات،
إنه جزء من روحي لا يمكنني العيش من دونه-
والأغاني أيضاً، يمكن تقسيم اللعبة
إلى أجزاء كثيرة
مثل الميلودي بوكس.
كيف تغني أغنية Track مثلاً؟
معروفة لدى كثير من الناس
في الموسيقى الخاصة بها،
كان الناس يسمعون فيقولون:
"من أنت؟ ما هذا؟" -- هذا عادي
هناك مغنٍّ اسمه بوب مارلي، أتعرفونه؟
وهناك أغنية له اسمها
No woman no cry
هل سمعتموها؟
لكن سأعلق عنها تعليقاً صغيراً بعد إذنكم
كنت أسمع الكثير من الناس
يترجمون هذه الأغنية بأن يقولوا:
إذا لم تتواجد الفتيات، لا يتواجد الحزن.
حسناً، ما هذا؟! كيف؟؟
لا، إنما هو كان يقول لها:
"يا امرأة لا تبكي"
هذه هي الأغنية، إذن فلنلعبها:
--
هذا هو الميلودي بوكس.
(تصفيق)
لكن كان من الأفضل أن
نغني أغاني مشهورة
تحوي فقط موسيقى كالهاوس
والترانس وما يشابهها،
كي نحظى بتفاعل الجمهور معنا.
مثل الأغنية التي تقول:
I like to move it
والناس تردد move it
وهكذا..
--
واحد فقط ردد الكلمة!
أتمنى فيما بعد
أن يرددها اثنان وثلاثة أيضاً
هيا قولوا move it!
--
موسيقى الهيب هوب:
كان الناس يستغربون
هذا الصوت،
وكيفية إصداره.
إذا حاول أحدكم أن يصدره من هنا،
ستتعب حباله الصوتية جداً،
سيأتي في نهاية اليوم وهو يهمس،
غيرَ قادر على الكلام.
عادة عندما نفعل هذا الصوت
نقفل حلقنا بشكل كامل،
ويصدر من هنا (البطن).
أجل والله من هنا،
لكنه يخرج من الفم طبعاً.
كنا نستخدم هذا الصوت
في موسيقى الـ dubstep
التي لا يحبها الكثير من الناس لأنها مزعجة،
حتى أنها تزعجني شخصياً لكني أحبها.
في بداية هذا الصوت كنا نصدره هكذا:
--
غريب قليلاً أليس كذلك؟
إن موسيقى dubstep عبارة عن ..
--
هذه هي موسيقى dubstep.
جسّد أسلوب البيتبوكس
كل أنواع الموسيقى
أي أن كل موسيقى لها نبض معين،
نبضات تكون على ايقاع معين،
وهي ما تعطي اسم البيت بوكس
(صندوق النبضات).
هناك تحد أكبر، أن تتحدى نفسك
وقدرات صوتك،
وهو نوع الأغاني الذي يسمى "الراب".
تعرفون الراب؟
الأشخاص الذين يلبسون ثياباً
فضفاضة ويلوحون بأيديهم.
أحدهم مشهور جداً وأحبه
جداً اسمه Eminem-
Slim Shady-
يغني أغنية:
--
حسناً؟ تفهمونها جميعاً طبعاً (بسخرية).
أما في البيت بوكس نجعلها هكذا:
--
حيث يمكن دمجهما معاً وتسمى راب بوكس:
هذا هو الراب بوكس وهو تحدي كبير.
-أنتم رائعون بالمناسبة أحبكم-
أتعرفون ما هذه؟ هذه هارمونيكا.
يحب لاعبو البيت بوكس
أن يطوروا هذا المجال كثيراً،
فبدلاً من أن نكون مقتصرين
على تنفيذ وأداء الموسيقا فقط،
يمكن أن ندخل إليها آلات موسيقية
وخصوصاً الآلات النفخية،
كالفلوت، هارمونيكا، ناي،
ساكسافون ومثيلاتها.
صوتها بمفردها أصلاً جميل جداً،
والبيت بوكس لوحده جميل،
لكنهما معاً حتماً سيشكلان شيئاً جميلاً.
هذا ما سأختم به لقاءنا وأتمنى أن تعجبكم:
--
هذا كل ما لدينا في TEDx
شكراً جزيلاً لكم، إلى اللقاء.